[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités
chaque jour rendez vous avec celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans les
yvelines et aujourd'hui rencontre avec
mustapha larbaoui le président du
football club de trappes l'académie du
club lance sa deuxième saison dédiée au
soutien scolaire pour les jeunes
footballeurs et nouveauté de taille à
cette année le numérique et fait son
apparition nous en parlerons avec lui en
direct sur ce plateau
rencontre également avec gallus coulon
un boxeur élan courtois de 26 ans qui
s'apprête qui s'apprête à combattre pour
la finale du tournoi de france et enfin
les petites bourrettes un groupe de
musique parisien sera en concert ce
vendredi à la verrière un concert en
guise de conclusion après leur résidence
dans la salle yvelinoise mais on débute
donc ce set 8 invités avec vous mustapha
larbaoui bonsoir bonsoir je le disais
dans les titres vous êtes le président
de l'étoile sportive de trappes et vous
n'êtes pas ici pour parler football en
tout cas uniquement au football mais
pour parler éducation puisque vous
lancer demain la deuxième saison de
votre académie une académie qui permet
notamment aux enfants d'avoir du soutien
scolaire gratuit avant l'entraînement de
football est la nouveauté je le disais
cette année c'est le numérique on va
revenir dessus mais déjà expliquez nous
comment un club de foot décide de
proposer du soutien scolaire à ces
jeunes footballeurs pourquoi vous avez
décidé de prendre une telle décision est
déjà plus d'un an d'abord merci de
m'inviter pour parler de ce type de
projet c'est beaucoup trop rares on
parle souvent d'autres choses dans le
cadre du football et c'est vraiment une
invitation que j'apprécie je préfère je
voudrais le dire à l'antenne
vous avez dit on va pas parler football
aujourd'hui on va parler de mandarin en
question mais en réalité c'est
consubstantiel cercle football pour moi
n'est qu'un prétexte depuis maintenant
12 ans que je fis ci à la présidence du
club de foot de trappes c'est vraiment
un prétexte pour 2 l'éducation c'est
juste vous accélérer le mouvement c'est
juste qu'on triche pas avec nos enfants
on leur dit qu'on est là pour faire du
foot donc du loisir du football mais en
même temps il ya un vrai travail qui est
fourni et ce travail permet d'élever des
levées j'ai envie de dire les âmes et en
même temps l'intellect des uns et des
autres donc le football c'est pas que
taper dans un ballon c'est aussi se
servir de sa tête auquel cas je reviens
à ce qui se faisait dans temps dans les
grandes écoles
londonienne les fameuses london school
où on apprenait aux enfants à devenir
les élites de la nation et le football
était un sport finalement prétexte pour
le loisir pour leur apprendre les mêmes
choses mais au travers du foot je
reviens un peu à ses fondamentaux depuis
douze ans c'est à dire que je veux
revenir l'élite le football il est
éducative de ma récente secrètement les
enfants dont vous vous occupez font
leurs devoirs avant l'entraînement c'est
ça alors c'est pas de devoir c'est du
renfort en maths et en français donc en
fait des paniers devoir donner pas
seulement 20 13 absolument pas c'est des
du renfort vous le disiez absolument pas
fait par vous absolument pas donc nous
enfin pour nous la priorité pour
l'éducation dont vous parlez c'est
l'éducation nationale et on se substitue
pas à eux
l'éducation parentale ce sont les
parents simplement le football a des
vertus comme tous les sports comme
toutes les activités culturelles et
sportives c'est donc un vecteur pour
transmettre des valeurs pour transmettre
des choses réelles et sérieuses pour
faire concrets pour nos téléspectateurs
on va chercher nos enfants à l'école
donc on a un bus et j'en profite pour
remercier les bus perrier et son
directeur qui est complètement partie
prenante depuis deux ans de 7,7 parti
j'ai peut-être pas loin de faire de pub
pardonnez moi pour les autres nous mais
si on veut dire parce qu'il est juste
extra c'est pour la bonne cause ce
garçon est extraordinaire je parle du
directeur on va les chercher on les
amène dans sur les sites est en passe au
goûter pour certains c'est ils ont parlé
goûter tout le temps et ensuite on passe
à la classe donc ces renforts maths
français et ensuite simplement on passe
au foot donc ils font toute la semaine
du lundi au vendredi vacances scolaires
comprises sauf les grandes vacances ils
font à la fois du renfort maths français
et du foot mais tout ça ça fait partie
et pour ses cures de renforts si je puis
me permettre il ya désormais le nul qui
s'installe rapidement à ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer quel est l'apport
du numérique qu'est ce que vous allez
faire avec le numérique donc en fait la
nouveauté pour parler de l'académie
entre guillemets même si c'est un peu
pompeuse c'est une réalité pour nous
c'est maintenant le numérique et la de
la même façon je vais remercier jean
michel fourgous qui a apporté sa pierre
à l'édifice c'est son truc dans sa
commune rythmant les élèves enfin les
légèrement leur auront des tables et
j'ai acheté aucune tablette par enfant
chaque tablette sera allumé avant
l'arrimage l'arrivée par dont des
enfants ils seront allumées uniquement
sur le compte le lien qui va sur la
plate forme est là on leur donnera le
comme au foot coup de sifflet une
demi-heure de français coup de sifflet à
une demi-heure de maths et orange
ensuite les tablettes et on les garde
parce qu'on voudrait en faire en sorte
que voir l'évolution de ces enfants tout
tout tout pardon tout non tout au long
de l'année je vais d'ailleurs l'apport
du numérique c'est aussi pour pour
captiver encore plus leur attention
cette génération qui était ultra
connectés aujourd'hui ces essais
obligeant mazières alors on peut
résister à tous on peut résister aux
nouvelles que sa malchance on peut
résister à tout ce qu'on veut mais à un
moment donné faut faire le faux proches
je répète c'est un prétexte et le foot
et la tablette mon prétexte à moi c'est
qu'ils passent pas leur temps sur leurs
tablettes sur des sites qui nous
emmènerait avère des dangers potentiels
je préfère que on les accompagne sur des
sites intelligent et là pour le coup
c'est ludique c'est éducatif c'est
progressif donc chacun va rentrer sur sa
classe de cm2 il s'agit de onze donc des
dix ans cm2 et ils ont des exercices
donc ça commence par des exercices
classiques dont qui lisent l'exercice et
après on leur propose pardon des leçons
et après on passe aux exercices et ils
sont corriger instantanément donc c'est
ludique c'est pratique ça va vite ça
leur plaît ça plaît aux parents aussi
j'imagine c'est la dernière question les
parents doivent soutenir dans cette
opération tiennent depuis deux ans et on
aimait bien l'étendre pour aller plus
loin et c'est probablement parce qu'on
va s'attacher à faire pour les
prochaines années merci mustapha
larbaoui d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
football club de trappes on reste dans
le sport pour la suite de ce sept huit
invités avec de la boxe cette fois ci
est l'un des plus grands espoirs de la
team farrugia à elancourt gallus coulon
de six ans va tenter de remporter ce
vendredi 4 novembre la finale du tournoi
de france contre massy taschereau du
club de fontenay sous bois notre
journaliste michael et demi d'euros l'a
rencontré au palais des sports d'el en
cours avant son entraînement on l'écouté
je suis confiant détendue la température
va monter crescendo au pour arriver au
jour j être fin prêt et comment vous
êtes vous préparé pour cette compétition
préparation il ya une phase je pense
dans chaque préparation il ya toujours
une phase de doute on sait pas voilà on
sait pas on sent pas forcément bien au
début et après vraiment qu'on a à
prendre plus en avant dans la
préparation plus les mises de gants et
n'arrive plus les entraînements se
durcit puisse on sait que voilà tu sais
que tu es là et
et tu sais que tu vas tenir et le jour j
étais prêt pour la guerre trois favoris
je ne sais pas j'ai pas figé pas vu un
panel de personnes pour me dire que
voilà tes favoris voilà peut-être je
sais pas en tout cas moi je sais que
là aujourd'hui c'est ma citation devant
moi je sais que une chose est sûre c'est
que peu importe qu'il y aurait eu devant
moi j'aurai la même détermination et
j'aurai la même envie de vaincre et je
vais partir aux quatre le 4 novembre et
je vais revenir avec la victoire j'en
suis persuadé j'ai confiance en moi et
je vais revenir accès du port il me la
faut coûte que coûte et quels seront les
recettes pour remporter la victoire est
ce qu'il y a une stratégie à mettre en
place des stratégies ou en séance et là
on connaît l'adversaire plus un petit
peu en connais quand même sa box qui
rentre dedans donc ça sera à distance
après on peut toujours se faire des
schémas avant combat etc mais arrivé le
jour j et ça peut ne pas ce qu'on a
voulu mettre en place ne se met pas
automatiquement place ça va être adapté
et surtout ça vous faut être intelligent
un box faut savoir s'adapter à
l'adversaire et
pour pouvoir sentir donner le meilleur
et sortir vainqueur de la rencontre il
ya énormément de bons boxeurs ici haïti
mph abuja il encourt est ce que vous
vous êtes inspiré de ses boxeurs comme
marvin petit a dit lahm ou m'a dit vous
en êtes inspiré oui bien sûr on
communique beaucoup tous sur les
préparations sur comment gérer le combat
et c'est donc ouais c'est des exemples
qui comprend et d'écossé toujours
déconseillée c'est toujours des bons
conseils à prendre pour
pour pouvoir après le jour j et l dans
les meilleures conditions possibles pour
gagner le combat est est ce que vous
avez un message à faire passer à votre
adversaire
ben si tu as toujours je sais pas si tu
me regardes mais celui avec le sourire
vraiment on espère que tu es vraiment
vraiment m'a dit que c'était solide
j'espère que tu es vraiment j'espère
juste plaisir j'espère pâtés jus soli
j'espère qu'ils étaient extrêmement
solide est vraiment dur parce que
vraiment le 4 le 4 novembre va falloir
que tu style vraiment puisé dans ses
ressources si tu veux repartir avec la
victoire et je doute que ça soit
possible la
culture pour terminer avec les petites
bourrettes un groupe de musique parisien
qui était au scarabée du 26 au 30
octobre dernier cette fin de résidence
est marquée par un concert le 4 novembre
toujours à la verrière mélanie poké est
allé à leur rencontre lors d'une
répétition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a commencé à jouer dans la rue dans
les bars
enfin c'est des copains qui nous ont
surnommé comme ça voilà une boîte c'est
un peu un pilier de comptoir à qui tu
quittes raconte sa vie gentiment et
voilà et du coup nous c'est un peu ce
qu'on fait
avec nos chansons petites bourrettes
c'est un groupe de chanson française
rock festif un peu plein de choses enfin
on part un peu dans toutes les
directions c'est un groupe qui existe
depuis
une quinzaine d'années montant est qui
qui tourne alors pas toujours été la
même équipe on mais on est deux à être
là depuis le début et puis on en est à
notre septième album phare sixième album
studio et entre temps on a fait à life
on s'arrête pas forcément sur un style
on peut faire une chanson qui va partir
du côté ambiance chansons de marins une
chanson qui va être la plus cotée
manouche après une of abraham en parlant
de farouk apple dans toutes les
directions on a commencé dans une
formule un peu acoustique musique de rue
à une époque où à paris c'est un peu
compliqué de faire des concerts
amplifiés donc nous on s'était un peu
adapté en faisant les
déchets sont enfin voilà une formule
plus acoustique quoi et après vu qu'on
nous proposait de jouer sur des plus
gros sel on a un peu électrifié notre
son et
et voilà aujourd'hui on travaille ça au
scarabée c'est là où même si de
l'extérieur on peut avoir l'impression
qu'on fout rien
ou pas grand chose en vrai on est tous
en train de cogiter un moment il se
passe un truc et si les trois premiers
jours en a l'air de plan des quatrième
et cinquième homme est à fond on joue à
huit heures par jour
et ça finit par donner quelque chose
d'intéressant donc c'est là on progresse
aussi vraiment parce que faut pas croire
que qu'il n'y a pas de marge de progrès
ou qu'on est donc
le fait de jouer plus fin plus tu joues
que j'ai prêté mon coloc et voilà c'est
l'occasion de jouer beaucoup en peu de
temps
[Musique]
fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme une
nouvelle édition demain même heure à
demain
[Musique]